I hate to reduce things to binaries but
the American right has a choice
option one keep doing what we are doing
which is the send strongly worded press
releases and op-eds and hope things get
better
Choice two indict indict use political
power and hope it gets better they're
both bad options I agree I like them the
the Forgiveness Arc for Donald like if
you're really pummeled and beaten down
by Society so hard and you still stand
up and forgive people for it that's a
message that will resonate for thousands
of years I think that's powerful not
gonna happen it could I think I think
they're lying in the polls too they're
they're trying to make the argument that
they want Trump to be the nominee so
they can beat him in 2024 but they
didn't beat him last time well I mean
they did beat him once they beat him
last time but they don't but but they
don't have anything right now there's no
one Biden can't do it Biden didn't
campaign he hit in his basement there
was a lockdown where melon bouts were
sent to everyone's home I totally agree
they don't have any of these tools